So I'm almost ready to talk about how,
what I did in this RecyclerView Part 3,
and that was to handle items, selection,
and choice, which is one of those
things that RecyclerView is missing.
So what I did was I created this
thing called ItemChoiceManager, and
this is not a complete implementation
of item choice and selection.
It is liberally copied from what
ListView actually does internally, and
you can see it actually uses a whole
bunch of ListView constants.
But basically it takes advantage
of sparse pooling arrays and
long sparse arrays and it, to store the
check states and the checked ID states.
And the big code that it probably, you
know, takes the most from ListView is
actually how it deals with
checking positions by ID.
This list I did not write for this.
Now, this is actually fairly
complicated if you see what it's doing.
It checks for nearby IDs and
searches through the list
to try to confirm these check positions,
and I think this kind of code is one of
the reasons why the framework team
was happy to see this functionality
taken out of RecyclerView, because
it is really tricky to implement.
And what we do actually for this,
we need to know when
the ViewHolder is bound.
So what we do is we actually have this
work together in conjunction with
the code that is in
the forecast adaptor.
In fact, in a weird way, this is sort of
a helper for the forecast adaptor far
more than it is actually a helper for
RecyclerView.
It also does a couple
of nice things here.
It actually restores and
saves instance states.
This I did right, mostly because I was,
I wanted to kind of
automatically do this.
And we don't automatically have a way of
saving these sparse arrays into bundles,
but we do have the way,
a way of saving them into parcels.
So I just implemented that here.
Just another function
that can be called, so
that we are saving these checked items.
And then finally,
getSelectedItemPosition,
very similar to ListView, returns
the first item that is selected, so
if you have multiple items like it,
it will return one.
Otherwise, it will return zero.
I did not implement the modal selection
stuff, so there is none of this,
you know, choiceMode multiple or
whatever.
But I do support a multiple modal here,
and you get an exception if you try to
use it, but
it does support both multiple and
single choice, basically adding that
functionality into RecyclerView.
And then so
the interesting stuff, of course,
is also what happens
inside of ForecastAdapter.
And this is pretty straightforward.
Whenever we bind the ViewHolder,
we also have to make sure that
we call ICM.onBindViewHolder,
same thing with onRestoreInstanceState
and on SaveInstanceState.
And we also added some helper functions,
so that other things
didn't have to call all the way in and
get access to the ItemChoiceManager.
So, like, getSelectedItemPosition,
et cetera, et cetera, is also supported.
We also added this nice
selectView function here.
And this is used to
implement a feature that I
thought was really really important.
And so it's one of the other things
I sort of slid into this one.
We have this concept of
auto selecting a view.
I kind of threw that in here,
because it was really unfortunate
to have views showing up.
So what I do is I wait to
see that we have children,
like we've been doing with
these OnPreDrawListeners, and
then once I know we have children,
then I go in SelectView,
either the position, if there already
is one, or if there isn't a position,
then we go and select the first one,
so that we have something selected,
which just looks a lot nicer
when you're in tablet mode.
So this is just a trick or a hack or a,
you know, reasonable way of doing it,
depending on how you want
to look at things, but, so
we're also taking advantage of that, and
that's the reason why we exposed
that SelectView functionality.
And other than that, it, you know,
looks pretty nice, works pretty well.
So that's a big piece of RecyclerView.
Now, the reason I didn't teach this, and
I didn't have you guys code this up,
is because I expect, in the next year or
so, we're going to have a better
solution if we're doing this kind of
item selection within RecyclerView.
RecyclerView is under heavy development,
and
there's all sorts of great stuff that's
gone into it in the last six months.
And I suspect more and
more of these things that are missing
from ListView are actually going to be
in RecyclerView in one way or another.
So here is my stat at doing
it in a reasonable way.
Perhaps the framework team will
come up with something better.
So that is finishing our
work on RecyclerView.
Again, you know,
take a look at those changes.
There's some interesting code in there.
The next thing we're going to get
into is scrolling in parallel.